salut il ya quelques jours je vous ai
fait la dernière vidéo de l'année
concernant la mémoire aujourd'hui je
vais vous faire la dernière vidéo de
l'année concernant les mathématiques ou
du moins les astuces mathématiques on a
au fond de sa tête juste le temps
d'installer la caméra en vous expliquant
de quoi il va retourner vous souvenez
que je vous avais appris dans l'année à
extraire mentalement
une racine carrée il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça je vous ai appris à
extraire mentalement une racine cubique
et pour finir l'année en beauté je vous
apprendrai extraire une racine 5e
mentalement
une racine cinquième c'est donc je
multiplie à un nombre par ce nombre par
ce nombre par ce nombre par ce nombre
ça donne un big résultats b de ce big
résultat vous pouvez extraire quel était
le nombre de départs qui a été
multipliée cinq fois ça sert surtout à
se la péter c'est toujours une très
bonne gymnastique en break et si vous le
faites je trouve ça cool de me dire que
maintenant il ya des gens qui en
regardant les vidéos savent faire
mentalement experts une racine carrée
une cubique et une 5e et je trouve que
c'est le plus simple à faire des 3c
extraction de racine mental que je vous
aurais donné cette année il ya une
petite chose à savoir néanmoins de la
j'arrondis tous ces résultats un
résultat ça fera 1 2 ça fra 33 safra 254
ça fera 1005 ça fera trois mille si ça
fera à 8700 fradi 7008 32000 et 9 69 et
baisser et bien c'est ça que vous devez
retenir c'est tout vous ne retenez que
ça 1 32 cent cinquante mille 3000 8000
17000 en 2068 c'est tout c'est la seule
chose
et avec ça vous savez extraire
tranquille une racine cinquième alors
pour le faire d'une manière fun vous
donnez votre calculatrice à quelqu'un ou
où la personne mais la calculatrice sur
son téléphone
vous lui demandez de penser à un nombre
à deux chiffres dans sa tête et de faire
fois son chiffre à son chiffre soit son
chez soi son chiffre quatre fois
d'affilée
imaginons qu'un personne prend 22 ça
fait 22 x 22 x 22 x 22 x 22 jan 5
millions 150 3632 cette personne-là doit
vous donner ce résultat l'offre soit
vous le dire soit vous montrez est
vraiment quasi instantanément vous savez
quel était son nombre de départs la
méthode est en deux étapes pour
retrouver le nombre de départs on va
dire le nombre initial on va l'appeler
comme ça nombre initial pour retrouver
l'unité du nombre initial pour garder
l'unité kiala c'est la même si ça finit
par deux c'est que c'était de 6 a fini
par 3,5 l'unité c'était 3 par quatre
cette unité était 4 etc
il n'ya pas s'embrouiller vous reste
plus qu'à retrouver maintenant le
chiffre des dizaines et pour ça c'est
extrêmement s'impose
vous supprimez les cinq premiers
chiffres donc l'unité les dizaines et
centaines les milliers les dizaines de
milliers vous supprimez sa de votre
champ de vision pour regarder que ce qui
après la dans l'exemple de 22 ans n'a
que de ses 51 et vous dans ce que vous
avez mémorisées vous regardez qu'est ce
qui est juste avant 51 donc dans notre
tableau on va dire mentalement on sait
qu'il ya un 30 250
donc qu'est ce qu'il ya avant 51 il ya
trente et trente est associé aux deux
donc de 2,22 on a bien notre 22 deuxième
exemple concret voici le résultat donc
j'avais choisi un nombre à deux chiffres
je les x lui-même et encore par lui-même
et encore par l'uimm et encore par
humaine ça m'a donné ça on sait déjà que
mon nombre initial finit par 1,5
l'unité est un 5 parce que celui ci
finit par 1,5 et si je supprime les cinq
premiers chiffres donc unités dizaines
centaines milliers dizaines de milliers
il me reste quoi il me reste 1845 et
qu'est ce qui est juste avant 1845 dans
mon tableau ses mille et mille sa
correspond à 4 donc je sais que c'est 45
cqfd voilà vous savez le faire
maintenant vous pouvez si vous voulez
vous faire un petit papier avec le récap
l'espèce de tableau qui à connaître
sinon vous trouvez un procédé
mnémotechnique avec toutes les vidéos
trous de mémoire qu'on a fait cette
année c'est pas compliqué non plus mais
là vous avez quand même un kit où il ya
moyen de bluffer les gens juste en en
faisant d'abord ok je vais essayer
d'extraire une racine carrée après une
racine cubique et puis je t'emmène
gentil par une racine 5e si cette vidéo
vous a plu n'oubliez pas de lalique et
et de vous abonner et rendez vous demain
à 17 heures charmant
m
là
[Musique]